well yeah in our cases I'd say that's
one of most important subjects we have
to manage because in the car business
again I come back to what we sell much
of what people used to evaluate vehicles
on and and you know a B analysis and
come down to their their session quality
quality's pretty much gone away there's
a perception gap on who has it and who
doesn't but if you get into the real
data and real measured quality by and
large almost identical you know ride fit
finish you know paint quality a lot of
the mechanical attributes of a vehicle
that historically and you know to be
totally honest the US industry did have
a significant gap to the Japanese and
Europeans that's pretty much gone and
they would admit it too so now what
you're judging on is is a lot of case so
of course value price still matters but
is the aesthetics and it is the design
and it's almost more like the clothing
industry now where you're gonna like it
or not like it and it's gonna look like
something that fits you something that
you'd like to wear something you'd like
to be seen in you know what's up-to-date
what's current and so that you know
design creativity is really our top
priority and making sure that the people
that we have in our in our design staff
in our studios that are working on
Cadillacs really highly motivated and
really have maximum opportunity for
creativity and are really let loose to
run and have to be brought back rather
than you know the opposite so that's
probably the primary or focus a lot of
time in a creativity spaces is ensuring
that our designers have they've got the
freedom to go and there's lots of
products in the market now that
exemplify that and my favorites iPod but
you look at that design of the iTouches
iPhones iPods and it's just the best
example I think in industry any industry
of where design wins out over
functionality and it delivers to now you
know you gotta make sure it does both
but really consumer choice and even
paying a premium is a lot of cases down
to the design so creativity is very very
critical in that space